what's going on people of Earth the
fifth season of The Walking Dead is
shuffling off into zombie hiatus this
show has become a mega hit and it's
stars instantly recognizable but it
wasn't always that way
so right now cover yourself and zombie
guts and grab your favorite one
instrument for a head trauma because
it's time for Walking Dead edition let's
kick it off with the group's leader Rick
Grimes Andrew Lincoln was largely
unknown in the US before the walking
dead but rom-com fans might remember him
as the creepy guy who tried to steal
Keira Knightley away from her husband in
love actually here's Andrew and all of
his British glory in the channel 4
comedy teachers and on our phones
there's a Claire lurking somewhere so
when you can't believe you'd ever marry
but one day you start considering as a
main B and before long it's not such a
bad idea and I don't know I didn't buy
the British accent I am NOT a pervert
next up is everyone's favorite crossbow
wielding redneck Daryl Dixon Daryl has
become a cult favorite but actor Norman
Reedus has been famous on college
campuses for years as the co-star of
underground hit the boondock saints
here's Norman in a pretty weird Japanese
commercial for a thing
[Music]
okay guys the only thing the Walking
Dead is more of than zombies is cast
members who used to be on the wire they
keep popping up everywhere
Chad L Coleman who plays Tyrese is also
known as Cudi the boxer with the heart
of gold but the Walking Dead wasn't his
first experience with shuffling corpses
he was also the voice of coach in the
zombies shoot-'em-up game left 4 dead 2
barricade your homes avoid all contact
with infected individuals wait for
official instructions tweet my ass
lawrence Gilliard jr. who played the
ill-fated bob is perhaps most famous as
the ill-fated D'Angelo Barksdale but he
also appeared in another true
cornerstone of American culture Adam
Sandler's the waterboy it's like my mama
always hid better safety did sorry mama
says that - oh no mom was the same yet
and Seth Gilliam who plays father
Gabriel also played a good guy detective
Ellis Carver you remember him
Kirk's partner all five seasons of The
Wire here he is nobly sacrificing
himself as sugar Watkins and Starship
Troopers
[Music]
[Applause]
speaking of TV shows with a cult
following this isn't actor Michael
Cudlitz his first appearance on a fan
favorite show before he was Abraham he
played Michelle Rodriguez his partner
Mike Walton unlost
holster your weapon alright let's take a
second talk about the bad boys of
Walking Dead first up is David Morrissey
aka The Walking Dead's biggest baddest
villain yet the governor he's just one
of several Brits faking a southern
accent on this show
but here's his appearance on the most
British show ever Doctor Who should I
have we met this is hardly the right
time for me to go through my social
hmm now that I think about it more
British I show Doctor Who or Downton
Abbey comment below
joining the governor in the Hall of
Shame is probably my favorite character
in the history of The Walking Dead Merle
Dixon played by veteran character actor
Michael Rooker this guy has been around
for years from Henry portrait of a
serial killer to cliffhanger to last
summer's guardians of the galaxy come on
yondu for life but here's what I'm sure
is his proudest acting moment getting
stink palmed by Jason Lee and Kevin
Smith small rats remember Shane
Rick's best friend turned attempted
murderer before he was rubbing his head
on the walking dead he was playing an
airhead in this bit part on How I Met
Your Mother Carlos I got a talk about
all the kick-ass ladies of The Walking
Dead
starting with Melissa McBride's Carol
chances are you've seen this clip from
the classic television series Walker
Texas Ranger pardon my french but I'll
be damned
Walker told me I have AIDS
well Haley Joel Osment what Walker
didn't tell you is that Melissa McBride
pops up in this same episode as the
nurse who apparently spends her time
looking lovingly at people in the
background hey Carol this is one Walker
you should have put out of its misery a
lot earlier up next Danai gurira who
plays badass sword master Michonne she
has perhaps the most critically
acclaimed entry on this list appearing
an Academy Award nominated film the
visitor you know the same thing happened
the other day I was in my apartment
taking a bath when veteran character
actor Richard Jenkins walked in on me
hey Richard Jenkins learn to knock
going to hurt you and who could forget
everyone's favorite farmer's daughter
Maggie played by lauren cohan
another Britt there's only one way to
skin a mongoose and it's my way here she
is showing us a little bit more than
basic cable nudity in the critically
acclaimed Van Wilder to the rise of Tosh
really they made another Van Wilder
alright you learned something every day
Maggie's main squeeze is Glen aka actor
Steven Yeun you've heard Steven as the
voice of the first avatar Wan in the
legend of korra real funny
you know what I don't need your help
I'll find it myself but here's his very
first TV appearance in a flashback
episode of The Big Bang Theory Sheldon
Cooper's apartment oh I bet you're here
to check out the room for rent yeah run
away dude run fast and finally we have
the Walking Dead's oldest and Krusty
ascared
Hershel played by veteran actor Scott
Wilson he's been in dozens of movies and
TV shows but here's one of his first
check out a young strapping two-footed
Hershel in 1967 s Truman Capote
adaptation in cold blood see that
gentleman over there
would you believe in love like that's
getting married well maybe Amy and Fred
Astaire but he's my best friend
the name is best man so who we leave out
by the way I know that we left out Karl
pretty much because we want all of you
guys in the comments section to say
where's Karl tell us who we miss tell us
what we missed best answer in the
comments section is gonna get a screen
junkies t-shirt I want to thank you guys
for watching I'm how redneck hit me up
on Twitter bye-bye
maybe I'm wrong but all that aren't they
just look brooding brooding meets
brooding meets brooding it looks like
three Goths hanging out in the candle
store that's what the new one looks like